hey Ryan we're the break I watch private
parts for the first time been a longtime
fan and I was surprised that Gary wasn't
in the movie more than he was well don't
forget Gary and didn't come into the
show until NBC and even not at the
beginning of Indy right you think
private parts should have had more Gary
ramen
by the way Ryan if you want to know
Gary's story by his book and also you'll
get we bought it yeah and you'll get his
list of favorite desert island Albert oh
here they are
so these are ten records that if I had
to go to a desert island I could only
bring how do we get him on a desert
island with me what would I bring well
that's somebody's he cares look in
Gary's book surprises here you know I'm
a huge Bruce Springsteen fan
oh no surprises here you know who knows
you're a Bruce get the [ __ ] out of here
Gary Mary no surprises no surprise like
like everyone's hanging oh he thinks
he's a superstar do you think in a book
I would ever write no surprises here I'm
a Bruce Springsteen fan I mean I
wouldn't even assume the audience knew
my favorite music oh his book is so
annoying I would definitely bring Born
to Run it's my favorite of all his
records and it was just a time and place
of my life where I could just go from
play and a place in his life when he
could do what I don't know I don't want
to know so I would definitely bring Born
to Run it's my favorite of all his
records and it was just a time and place
of my life where I could just go from
the beginning to the end and love every
song on that's ridiculous well that make
any sense
that's what I'm saying I knew it's a
time in his life when he well I could
listen to every song and I had to
couldn't take the needle off I was
paralyzed in the chair Gary didn't the
guy write the book for you I mean I mean
there was somebody helping
this part I'm reading spontaneously how
about reading directly there's a list
but it's from an actual written document
right yeah well what does that have to
do with the time you liked what was
going on in your life that you could go
Guinea man what does it mean I was
thinking that it was a time place in my
life where this record really had an
impact on what I should but you didn't
tell us would be what was going on it's
a list Robin not a [ __ ] podcast
uh-huh Gary Gary honestly I'd rather
listen to John Heinz top ten fast food
straws Asia by Steely Dan I really loved
that bad that I really loved that record
I saw them recently in New York where
they played Asia live and the record
still holds up that record still holds
up you saw them live that record came
out it was different than anything I'd
heard before
and I you know they did a study anyone
who purchased this book has been
committed to a mental institute go back
I listened to it a lot it still holds up
Hotel California
the Eagles I'm their own pulling out hit
records here but what could I say on
what planet does anyone care what his
top albums are right I know I'm pulling
out a lot of hits here but what can I
say every song at Hotel California is
amazing I just got a remastered version
of it and it still holds up everything
holds them everything holds up and now
another record holds up thriller Michael
Jackson I could what does it hold up
though it holds up it holds up it'll do
when I was working at the record store
it was just a pivotal time of my life
and every song on the record was a
pivotal again we had a time in his life
why was the record store the pivotal
tunt would you stop smelling your finger
would you have sex last night
how is making fun of me about to smell
my fingers know what was seriously yeah
but there was a pivotal time in your
life I was working at the record store
and it was a pivotal time in my life
but he never explained I was putting
wickets in the cutout and I feel I'm at
a pivotal point my life I love when Gary
says is a pivotal part time in his life
so he bought Michael time in a place
every song and everything holds up